[Music]
and welcome to a special edition of
Hannity the Trump agenda and now
President Trump he rocked the crowd he
delivered a rousing speech at CPAC 2018
tonight for the hour we have the
highlights and of course reaction all of
this will check in with judge Denis pero
but we start with President Trump's plan
to protect American schools and students
following this tragedy in Florida let's
take a look it's time to make our
schools a much harder target for
attackers we don't want them in our
schools we know we don't want when we
declare our schools to be gun-free zones
it just puts our students in far more
danger far more danger
[Applause]
well-trained gun adept teachers and
coaches and people that work in those
buildings people that were in the
Marines for 20 years and retired people
in the army the Navy the Air Force the
Coast Guard people that are adept adept
with weaponry and with guns they teach I
mean I don't want to have a hundred
guards standing with rifles all over the
school you do a concealed carry permit
and this would be a major deterrent
because these people are inherently
cowards if they thought like if this guy
thought that other people would be
shooting bullets back at him he wouldn't
have gone to that school he wouldn't
have gone there
it's a gun-free zone it says this is a
gun-free zone please check your guns way
far away and what happens is they feel
safe there's nobody going to come out
this way you may have and remember if
you use this school as an example this
is a very big school with tremendous
floor area and a lot of acreage it's a
big big school good school a big big
school you'd have to have a hundred and
fifty real guards looking at one guard
he didn't turn out to be too good I will
tell you that he turned out to be not
good he was not a credit to law
enforcement that I can tell you that I
can tell you
but as I've been talking about this idea
and I feel it's a great idea but some
people that are good people are opposed
to it they don't like the idea of
teachers doing that but I'm not talking
about teachers you know CNN went on they
said Donald Trump wants all teachers
okay fake news folks fake nose fake news
I don't want a person that's never
handled a gun that wouldn't know what a
gun looks like to be armed but out of
your teaching population out of your
teaching population you have 10% 20% of
very gun adept people military people
law enforcement people they teach they
teach and and something I thought of
this morning you know what else and I
thought of it since I found and watch
Peterson the deputy who didn't go into
the school because he didn't want to go
into the school okay he was tested under
fire and that wasn't a good result but
you know what I thought of as soon as I
saw that these teachers and I've seen
them at a lot of schools where they had
problems these teachers love their
students and the students love their
teachers in many cases these teachers
love their students and these teachers
are talented with weaponry and with guns
and that's they feel safe and I'd rather
have somebody that loves their students
and wants to protect their students than
somebody standing outside that doesn't
know anybody and doesn't know the
students and frankly for whatever reason
decided not to go in even though we
heard lots of shots being fired inside
the teachers and the coaches and other
people in the building the Dean the
assistant dean the principal they can
they love that people they want to
protect these kids and I think we're
better with that and this may be 10% or
20% of the population of teachers etc
it's not all of them but you would have
a lot and you would tell people that
they're inside and the beauty is it's
concealed nobody would ever see it
unless they need it in its concealed so
this crazy man who walked in wouldn't
even know who it is that has it that's
good cuz our bad that's good and a
teacher would have shot the hell out of
him before he knew what happened and
we've gotten grabbing people on the Left
bashing the Second Amendment and trying
to blame the NRA for the shooting in
Florida Oh president Trump defended our
constitutional rights to keep and to
bear arms here's what he said don't be
complacent okay don't be complacent
because if they get in they will repeal
your tax cuts they will put judges in
that you wouldn't believe they'll take
away your Second Amendment which we will
never allow to happen they'll take away
you second I'll remember that they will
take away thank you they will take away
those massive tax cuts and they will
take away your second America by the way
if you only had a choice of one what
would you rather have the second
amendment or the tax cuts go ahead
second amendment tax cuts second
amendment I'm gonna leave it at the
second amendment I don't want to get
into that battle all right we're gonna
say you want Matt we're gonna say you
want the second amendment the most but
we're gonna get them all there's nobody
that loves the Second Amendment more
than I do
and there's nobody that respects the NRA
they're friends of mine they backed us
all the great people the Patriots but
but the great people but we really do
have to strengthen up really strengthen
up background checks we have to do that
and we have to do for the mentally ill
we have to do very well we don't want
people that are mentally ill to be
having any form of weaponry we have to
be very strong over so we're gonna do
that and I really believe that Congress
is going to get it through this time and
they have a different leader they have
somebody that wants to get it through
not somebody that just all talk no
action like so many of these folks this
is somebody that wants to get it through
we also need to create a culture in our
country that cherishes life and human
dignity that's part of what we're
talking about a culture that condemns
violence and never glorifies violence we
need to force to real human connections
and turn classmates and colleagues into
friends and neighbors that want to fight
for us we're not just having a
conversation about school safety you've
had conversations in all fairness I'm
pretty new on this job we're here a
little more than a year I've been
watching this stuff go on for 20 years
the president gets up everybody's
enthusiastic for the first couple of
days then it fades fades fits nothing of
it gets done we want to see if we can
get it done let's get it done right we
really owe it to our country
I've been watching for a long time seen
a lot of words and I've seen very little
action and you know if you think about
it most of its just common sense it's
not do you love guns do you hate guns
it's common sense it's all common sense
and and some of the strongest advocates
about what I'm saying are the strongest
advocates I know them very well
political people the strongest advocates
for the Second Amendment but this is
common sense
in addition to securing our schools
we're also implementing a strategy to
secure our streets we want our kids to
be safe everywhere they go
whether they're in a classroom walking
home from school or just outside playing
with their friends every child deserves
to grow up in a safe community
surrounded by a loving family and to
have a future filled with opportunity
and with hope now also today the
president is making major foreign policy
news announcing sweeping new sanctions
against the rogue regime North Korea now
the Trump administration is saying that
these sanctions are the largest ever
against Pyongyang and they're meant to
cut off money and supplies to the
dictator Kim jong-un and is using of
course that money to advance his nuclear
program here's the president announcing
those new sanctions earlier I do want to
say because people have asked North
Korea we imposed today the heaviest
sanctions ever imposed on a country
before
and frankly hopefully something positive
can happen we will see but hopefully
something positive can happen but that
just was announced and I want to let you
know we have imposed the heaviest
sanctions ever imposed and also the
president of a list that has many
accomplishments and these are the things
that the liberal mainstream destroyed
Trump media never covers because you
know what it doesn't fit their narrative
take a look for the last year with your
help we have put more great conservative
ideas into use than perhaps ever before
in American history we've confirmed a
record number so important of Circuit
Court judges and we are going to be
putting in a lot more and they will
interpret the law as written and we've
confirmed an incredible new Supreme
Court justice a great man Neil Gorsuch
we've passed massive biggest in history
tax cuts and reforms it was called the
tax act tax cut Act and jobs we had to
add jobs into it because we're picking
up tremendous number of jobs 2.7 million
jobs sincere 2.7 remember this not only
did we get the tax cuts which everybody
said we wouldn't get and by the way
repealed in that tax cut the individual
mandate which is a tremendous thing this
is where you're forced to pay in order
not to have health care ok is that great
you pay for the privilege of not having
health care so you're subsidizing lots
of other people that's gone I know
people came up to me with tears in their
eyes they're saying I'm forced to pay
not to have health care it's very unfair
and by the way we're having tremendous
plans coming out now health care plans
at a fraction of the costs that are much
better than Obamacare and except for one
senator who came into a room at 3
o'clock in the morning and went like
that we would have had health care too
we would have had health care too
think of that but I think we may be
better off the way we're doing its piece
by piece by piece
Obamacare is just being wiped out the
individual mandate essentially wipes it
out so I think we may be better off and
people are getting great health care
plans and we're not finished yet but
remember one person walked into a room
when he was supposed to go this way and
he said he was going this way and he
walked in and he went this way
and everyone said what happened what was
that all about
boy oh boy who was that I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't want to
be controversial so I won't use his name
okay what a mess but it's all happening
anyway it's all happening anyway and
we've at the same time eliminated a
record number of job-killing regulations
and people are going back to work no
president has ever cut so many
regulations in their entire term okay as
we've cut in less than a year we've
ended the war in American energy we were
in war and we've ended the war on
beautiful clean coal remember this
virtually as soon as I got into office
we approved the Keystone XL pipeline and
the Dakota access pipelines which would
never have been approached we knocked
out the Paris climate Accord would have
been a disaster
would have been a disaster for our
country when you look at what's
happening to our country it's incredible
and the fundamentals are so strong the
stock market I just see with all of the
ups and downs since election day is up
37% from election 37% was up up a
hundred up 200 up 1000 up 150 up 90 up
63 I said goods that's better you know
hey we've got seven years to go folks
you know at all we got a long time to go
just in finishing our countries starting
to do very well our economy is blazing
jobs are at a record level jobs are so
good
2.7 million jobs created since the
election unemployment claims have
reached a 45 year low african-american
unemployment has reached the lowest
level in our history
hispanic unemployment has reached the
lowest level in our history
women women unemployment is at the
lowest level in 18 years wages are
rising for the first time in many many
years small business confidence is at a
record high and thanks to our massive
tax cuts millions of americans are
getting to keep a great percentage of
their money instead of paying it to a
government that throws it out the window
so I just leave you with this we have to
fight Nancy Pelosi they want to give
your money away
they want to give your money away they
want to end your tax cuts they want to
do things that you wouldn't even believe
including taking your second Amendment
rights away they will do that they will
do that so we have to get out there and
we have to fight in 18 like never before
just the way you fought with us just the
way you fought with us you fought so
hard and you were so tough and you were
so smart you were so smart and you know
what I know for a fact you did the right
thing because we're looking at the
numbers and the numbers even they have
to give credit for the kind of numbers
that we're producing nobody has ever
seen anything like it